[just an everyday cereal ritual]
Mrrrhech.
[suddenly WADE]
AH!
[choking]
Oh!
So... what?
Ah, man...
...you can't just sneak up on someone like that.
It's all right, man, I didn't mean to scare ya.
Ah, it's all right...
...I just almost choked on my cereal.
Just... don't do it again.
Sorry!
Thanks.
[suddenly RYAN]
BWAH!
Sorry, man.
Clogged your toilet again.
Hah.
[suddenly BOB]
WAAH!
(Whaaat?!)
What you doin'?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?!
[offscreen]
We can't seem to figure out how the TV works.
Oh... Let me come help you!
[NOPE]
[static noise]
Try this one?
(Mark) Guys...
Guys!
Good night!
[increasing confusedness]
[...also, Tiny Box Tim! <3]
[suddenly DANIEL]
WAH!
Just wanted to uh...
...see how you do things.
GET. OUT.
[suddenly WADE AGAIN]
AH!
[punch of friendliness]
Hah.
[even more increasing confusedness]
(Bob) WOAH!
(Bob) Occupied.
Wait...
...do we take our clothes off...
...before we shower?
[suddenly RYAN AGAIN]
I'd say yeah.
[MAXIMUM CONFUSION]
[PLOTTWIST - It was all a dream!]
[ORWASIT?!]